my business behind bars the bad boys
bakery is finally up and running
but my six months in Brixton prisons are
almost up last day you'll miss me
tomorrow thank you the bakery is not yet
in profit so I've invited Secretary of
State for justice Ken Clark and prisons
minister Crispin Blount to see if they
can provide vital investment and take my
pilot business to the next level
well cook him lunch and in many ways
it's gonna be great for him just to a
get up to speed what we've been doing
but be a chance of the boys to actually
show him you know what they can produce
inside this prison kitchen every day I
say to myself why did it have to come to
prison to get this experience you know
there's a good experience and I just
wish I had this experience on the
outside it's just made me prepared so we
now go out I'm just ready to work this
is the most important meal my brigade
have cooked so far the minister decision
has the power to make or break the bad
boys bakery big day today we have a very
special guest coming down you're gonna
be cooking for him and a chance to show
what we've been doing we've got Ken
Clark coming down he's the man that
oversees every big decision in the
justice system yep
so it's a big one I want to see some
energy in here I want you to do yeah
exactly
let me put this way
he's the [ __ ] side to him coming if you
didn't understand how important this is
this place is not close we have to make
an immediate impression
I know Ken Clark like seafood so I've
asked the boys to create traditional
British canapes to showcase what they've
learned
[Music]
and better discipline is told me of what
more belief in myself now they've earned
my trust I can give him something
without lying I'll be doing myself
literally two hours later it takes a
long time to get that trust I know I had
in school even all had jobs I never have
your skill gives you other avenues yeah
I mean got any questions for Kenda sleep
they might only be canapes but today the
Scotch eggs on the menu are odd cuisine
quails eggs about I've never heard of
this stuff in my life yeah B can you
[ __ ] believe it I'm sawing pepper in
your egg white go my mom gets to go
because you're putting your man I gotta
eat it it's a quail egg I just want it
without training from you but yeah